Vendors have come up with a variety of strategies for
dealing with component versioning issues.
At a minimum, version numbers are used.
When deployment is performed the version number is used to
perform a compatibility check.
Other strategies that vendors have taken include the following.
Some vendors have ad hoc compatibility rules.
That is the rules pertain to the particular version and change between versions.
Some vendors claim that they have immutable interfaces,
that is the vendor promises never to change the interface.
Some vendors guarantee backward compatibility.
Changes can be made but old versions are guaranteed to continue working.
Some vendors have sliding windows of supported versions.
That is, they will, support the previous five versions or
the previous three versions.
Some vendors take a middle ground saying they're going to break compatibility
only with major releases that include major new features.